[Applause]
this body cam footage released by los
angeles police shows officers responding
to reports of an assault at a clothing
store on the 23rd of december the
officers are clearly on
edge at the scene they find a woman on
the floor bleeding but alive
the 24 year old suspect daniel elena
lopez is at the end of the aisle the
officers opened fire
three shots are fired with devastating
consequences lopez is killed but one of
the bullets passes through into the
changing room and hits a 14 year old
girl an innocent victim who is in the
cubicle with her mother she was
pronounced dead at the scene
mourners left tributes for the young
girl while the chief of police in los
angeles described the incident as
devastating and traumatic but the force
has questions to answer
lapd officers have shot 38 people 18 of
them fatally in 2021 a big increase from
the seven killed in 2020. the league of
united latin american citizens america's
largest latino civil rights organization
has called for change saying this
incident is only the latest in a rash of
recent lapd shootings involving latinos
it's apparent that the days of shoot
first asked question second are rearing
their ugly head again in one of the
nation's law enforcement agencies
the california department of justice is
investigating the shooting the suspect
it turns out did not have a gun and an
innocent young girl has died another
unhappy chapter in america's history of
gun violence charlotte lomas sky news